[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here and part of
being a creator not just a youtuber but
a creator
is creating for multiple platforms so i
happen to make videos i put them on
youtube and that's the number one place
to go but obviously i'm on twitter i'm
on instagram i'm on facebook there's
other places that i talk to you outside
of youtube and that's for creative
reasons but also you just don't you
don't put all your eggs in one basket
that's never a smart thing to do so you
don't own your audience on any one
platform so you diversify but i've
always been thinking just because i get
asked in like every interview pretty
much ever like what would you do if
youtube disappeared tomorrow or what
would you do if youtube fell off like
right now
where would you be but like i never
really had a good answer to that because
it always i mean youtube has just been
massive i would say too big
to do that too big to instantly
disappear if it ever started failing
there would be a trajectory and i would
see it and i could do something about it
so i've never really had a good answer
to that but the answer i always gave was
just look there's no better place for
video creator right now in 2018 as it is
than youtube and as long as that is
still true then i will still upload my
tech videos to youtube they have it all
they have all the tools they have all
the videos they have all the stats they
have all the eyeballs they have all the
monetization they have every feature you
could want as a youtube watcher and as a
youtube creator all in one place so if
you want to grow yourself as a creator
and get eyeballs on your work you go to
youtube if you want to look for a video
online
you go to youtube.com it's just that
simple but you can never be on top
forever so as this whole online video
thing just continues to blow up everyone
wants a piece of youtube's pie everyone
wants a bite of of that massive pie
youtube has right now so you might have
seen it in the news there's company
after company just takes a shot at
youtube's throne and it may be called
like the next big whatever or maybe
they're saying youtube's falling off and
it's getting replaced i've seen the
story a million times like periscope for
example you remember that right live
videos they got bought out by twitter
and they still do their thing but it's
it's very niche there's no search for
like an archive of stuff it's not really
a youtube competitor snapchat uh there
as a creative person there have been
plenty of plenty of creative people on
snapchat
but for the longest time many many years
snapchat didn't really focus on those
creators i mean what did you see in the
discover page year after year it's daily
mail that kind of stuff so eventually it
started leaving and there's no real
monetization option for snapchat they
kind of turned the page a little bit too
late on that vine vine we basically saw
the whole life cycle of a youtube
competitor through vine it grew up
through 100 percent just creative people
there were no
like tv talk show hosts or i mean no
offense to tv people but really what we
went to vine for was the people who just
made stuff that was what vine was built
on but even with all these creators they
couldn't find a way to financially
sustain it the monetization was never
really secure
and vine crumbled it couldn't last so
r.i.p vine those vimeo they've kind of
just been around for a while sort of in
the background vimeo exists i think as
the most complete possible competitor to
youtube as a video site you know they
have monetization they have search they
kind of have this focus on high quality
you can find short films there and
things like that but there are like 10
000 times less eyeballs on vimeo than
youtube so if you're picking where to
upload your video if you want it to get
seen or you want to get feedback on it
people are going to pick youtube every
time that's what creators mean when they
say the word platform it's almost
literally like a platform for your work
to be visible above the rest because of
things like search and then even
facebook video is another one that's
come up recently that's had a lot of
people talking and i think they even
understood that creators are a big
driving force behind making a successful
video platform but still somehow like 90
of the videos i see on facebook are
stolen from youtube so even if they do
get monetization right
search is kind of a dumpster fire on
facebook i have no idea how to search to
find a certain facebook video
and yeah the copyright stuff is kind of
a big deal google plus
do i even
do i even need to say more than that so
still through all that for the last
decade through all of these companies
taking their shots at youtube and trying
to get a slice of that pie some of them
with more success than others still at
the top remains youtube.com is the place
to go to make videos and to go to watch
videos so then a couple weeks ago i was
at wwdc which is apple's event and while
i was there in san francisco had a quick
meeting with instagram where they wanted
to show me a video app they were working
on
okay interesting i've seen videos on
instagram already but this is a whole
separate thing and they showed it to me
and it was it was pretty intriguing and
it kind of came with like this silent
like you in and this is now what was
just announced today instagram tv or ig
tv
and it honestly feels like it has the
most potential or what i would say is
the most complete set of
factors to potentially be
like that second place big video
platform for creators like the eyeballs
first of all yes they have it people use
instagram definitely people can just do
instagram and have their work found
through that they just rolled over a
billion
monthly active users on the platform so
the the platform is big and that's not a
problem and then search they kind of
have the beginnings of search they have
i mean there's hashtags as we already
know but they have the explore page and
they kind of have their algorithms in
place to help people find content so
they don't do search great yet but i
feel like discovery will also not be a
problem and then the secret sauce that
they've nailed that i think you have to
hit the nail on the head with is
a creator focus and they've had that
everywhere if you look in the app store
listing for this new igtv app it's
creators it's it's not like like i said
again like the tv late night hosts or
anything like people who are like a-list
celebrities it's actually people who
create no offense again to like jimmy
kimmel or whoever i don't whatever they
have obviously live video on instagram
which people have been getting more into
on youtube even twitch as another
competitor but twitch feels like its own
separate like dedicated to live
streaming type of site which is why i
think it's a solid second place right
now but instagram also has stories too
which youtube has been also awkwardly
trying to get into which i don't even
think they should so it seems like
instagram has it all the only real
question mark is
will they be paying creators and while i
can't definitively say that they will
monetize the platform just like youtube
i can be pretty sure
they are going to be doing some sort of
monetization that will benefit creators
so yeah i'm on igtv now i'm on instagram
tv i have uploaded my first video we'll
be messing with it more very shortly but
there's a desktop uploader i can do red
footage
it's all it's all there for me so we're
gonna i mean the 1.4 million people who
already follow me on instagram are
already there they're already subscribed
to the igtv channel so if you're not
already subscribed or following on
instagram make sure you do that
but uh it's it's getting rolling and
it's getting started basically i'm
excited for what's to come i'm excited
the whole point of this video is i'm
excited about the competition to youtube
actually taking a step up competition
is good for us users of the services if
there is no competition to the iphone as
much as you love the iphone it would
never get better if there was no phone
that's coming up and chomping on the bit
and trying to steal your customers
that's the kind of stuff that benefits
the people who are using it so that's
why i'm happy about youtube competition
obviously the biggest complaint about
igtv is vertical video
which if you asked me a couple years ago
i too was staunchly anti-vertical video
because i make youtube videos so here's
the thing instagram's pitch is all about
the mobile experience first and we all
hold our phones vertically and there's
been snapchat stories and periscope and
instagram stories and all this vertical
video hello we've had square video on
instagram for a while now and nobody was
really complaining so i feel like if
vertical video is the biggest complaint
about igtv then that's actually probably
a pretty good sign i am willing to
experiment with and work within the
confines of nine by 16 video there as
i've already started messing with and
it's actually kind of interesting so
yeah we'll we'll see how it goes um i'm
over there now the point was
competition's good that's about all i
had to say for this one it's kind of a
rambly video but i hope you enjoyed
thank you for watching catch you over on
igtv but of course catch you in the next
youtube video
peace